hi everyone it's Joanna here today's
workout is perfect for one of those
light and easy days where you want to
take things slightly less intense yet
you still want to get a good workout in
so we will be going through a series of
exercises that will stretch and
strengthen the body so let's start your
day feeling energized or and your day
feeling amazing let's get into it
[Music]
so let's get straight into the workout
we'll start things off easy and I want
you to be fully aware of your body
throughout this exercise okay so let's
start right at the edge of your mat the
first workout is going to be inchworm to
downward dog if you're starting off you
can start by bending your knees slightly
keep a slight bend on your knees and
just reach towards the floor and slowly
inch forward
to the end of the mat
keeping your body in a solid plank
position push your butt up
and back into a plank and slowly inch
yourself back okay as you reach up
inhale breathe in release
inch forward
getting into a nice solid plank flat
back push your butt up
and slowly inch yourself back
breathe in now let's keep your legs
slightly straight okay straight legs
feel the stretch on your hamstrings
into a nice solid plank pushing to the
ground
Pike your butt up into a downward dog
back into a plank
and
straight legs push yourself back up and
breathe in good right let's move on to
the next exercise let's slowly inch
forward and let's start in a high plank
position this is called the world's
greatest stretch so step your left foot
forward release your arm stretch up feel
the stretch on your back your legs look
up release push your back push your leg
back into a plank position and change
side good so I want you to make sure
that the back leg is always straight
reach up look straight up release solid
plank
and change
so
be fully aware of the movement
stay connected with your body
and remember to breathe in and out good
solid plank step forward release
one more time push back
and slowly inch back up all right good
job all right the next workout is going
to be a little bit more challenging so
again let's get into a plank position
let's start on your knees give me one
push-up
and now push yourself back into a better
position stretch your back repeat one
push-up
and up push yourself back okay for more
challenge
stay on your toes one nice solid push-up
so this is the part where we will be
strengthening your body push up and push
your butt back feel the stretch on your
back
good one solid push up choose your
option
either on your toes or on your knees
really push your butt back feel the
stretch on your back
up
nice looking really strong
without
and good job okay now let's get into a
standing position all right so the next
exercise is going to be a narrow squat
with a Twist so keep both legs together
again what I'm going to do is reach up
and as we squat down twist
to one side
and reach up and twist to the opposite
side so try to get your elbow across
good stretch
and feel the work on your legs good job
it's an easy up stretch
a twist
remember to breathe in
and breathe out
as you twist keep going
I'm breaking a sweat
feeling my heart rate
slowly increasing one last twist and
good all right now
short breaks okay step right in front of
your mat now let's get into a reverse
lunge position with any driver so
find your balance step back reverse
lunge and drive your knee up okay
reverse lunge and drive your knee up
simple now let's add your arms view the
stretch reverse arm Rivers lunge and
forward so find your balance
good
out
and in
fine and look at one focal point
you should feel the work
on the front leg
job stretch
as you lunge back
view the stretch
your arms and your back
through the work
on your leg
and good all right change the opposite
side okay your left leg right now all
right are we ready let's work the legs
step your right leg back
reach up
and in good job I know
let's work on your balance as well
it's going to be a little bit
challenging
Stay With Me look straight ahead
and just piece of breathing
breathe in as you lunge back
breathe out
as you drive your knee up
good job
and up
really well done ah nice
so find your own rhythm
and keep to it
last one more
up
and just release very very well done
okay we're going back down onto the
floor all right so let's get back into a
high plank position this time it's going
to be three legged dog with a crunch so
lift your left leg up
all right hike your butt up and drive
your knee towards your elbow pack it up
push it up feel the stretch and drive it
in good job
again this workout will stretch and
strengthen the body
okay take it slow
really be aware of all the movements all
the muscles in your body working
together push it up
making sure that your hips are aligned
do not over twist bring it back forward
good
[Music]
there you go
drive your knee in good job and drop
your leg okay now let's change to the
other side are we ready remember to push
into the ground give me a solid plank do
not Pike or arch your butt ready
the opposite leg up and now drive it in
good job push it as high up as you can
and try to drive your knee towards your
elbow
breathe in
good and breathe out
push it up Hike It Up good
a few more
up
moving forward
that's one more
forward
and place your feet down very very good
job okay now let's just push yourself
back up okay take a short break if you
need to we're working on alternating
side plank so again let's start in a
high plank position and all I'm going to
do is release
your left arm twist to the side drop it
back down and now change
to the other side and as you twists
remember to keep your hips high so do
not dip your hips okay do not drop it
keep it up high
and change
twist look straight up
working on your balance as well as your
core strength
[Music]
side going
oh
light and easy day
yet still slightly challenging and drop
it back down okay now let's lie flat
onto the mat okay
come down onto the mat
and we're working on glute Bridge Okay
so drive your butt up
and what I'm going to do is drive your
left knee in
keep your left leg straight bring it
back down and place it back down so
reverse
the leg oh I can hear my knees clicking
what about you
straight and back down so remember to
always maintain a glute Bridge position
all right do not dip it drop it high
bring it high up knee in up as straight
as you can
view the work on your quads up feel the
work on your glutes and back down up
job there you go
and back down okay oh two more exercises
and you will get a short break all right
next is going to be a crab toe touch so
what I'm going to do is get into a
reverse plank position all I want to do
is reach for the opposite toe
feel the stretch along your hamstrings
but yet at the same time
this is a total body strengthening
workout okay
touch if this is too difficult
start with
your shin
okay for him
for more challenge reach four
your toes whoo find your balance
reach
tap
tap
and tap good job
you're almost there
last one more
and just drop it down all right final
exercise let's get into a reverse
position
start on all fours okay all I want to do
is hover your knees off the floor and
shoot your right leg through releasing
your left arm
and get back into all fours and reverse
the direction so this is sort of like a
brick dancer move release
and up again a lot of core work a lot of
balancing work
and a lot of strengthening work as well
release
don't rush through the workout
one move at a time
shoot your leg through
and drive it back
remember remember to keep your knees off
the mat
one last one more
the other side
and just drop it down okay
very very well done
that is the end of the first round take
a short one minute break keep yourself
hydrated wipe your sweat and guess what
we want to repeat the entire sequence
again
[Music]
right welcome back I'm sure you are all
warmed up and feeling really stretched
right now so for the second round let's
push yourself a little bit further and
choose the harder option okay right
let's start with the first workout step
right at the edge of your mat the first
workout is going to be inchworm to a
downward dog so keep your legs straight
try to reach for the floor and slowly
inch forward solid plank push your butt
up
and back into a plank and slowly inch
back take a deep breath in
breathe in all the good energy release
and slowly inch forward okay hike your
butt up push your heels into the ground
nice solid Plank and slowly
inch back breathe in deep breath good
release
inch forward
up
Plank and slowly inch back within
good job
keep with the flow push your butt up and
just stay in this plank position okay we
want to get into the world's greatest
stretch so dry field
left foot forward remember as you
release
keep the back leg straight so we're
going to strengthen the leg at the same
time don't drop your knees keep your
legs straight
and feel the stretch along the back
good drop it
remember legs straight throughout okay
nice solid plank
forward
push it back
good
there you go
feel the stretch along your hip flexors
and your inner thighs as well up
back down
one last one
on each side back down
and back all right are you ready to stay
in this plank with me we're going to get
into push-up to Bear okay so choose your
options either on your knees or on your
toes are we ready nice strong push up
let's go one push-up
push it back
good push up
and back remember
do not
dip your hips down okay
nice solid push-up and into a bear
if it's getting tough
get onto your knees all right
push it back
and good job
this is the strengthening part
pushy back
push up
I promise you only few more and we are
done oh my gosh I am sweating all right
now let's get back up the next workout
is going to be a narrow squat with a
Twist so I'm going to
Go and show you the side view so reach
up as you squat down twist to the
opposite side and
twist
reach up good
remember that
we're working on your quads and your
glutes so remember to push
your butt back
imagine that you're sitting on a chair
okay and that's a Twist look as far back
as you can good job twist
foreign
[Music]
the next workout is going to be a slight
challenge we'll be working on your
balance so step forward
we're getting into reverse lunge with
knee driver are we ready let's go step
back
and up let's do it together with your
hands up
good job
breathe in as you lunge down breathe out
as you come up again the tip here
is to look straight ahead find one focal
point
and do not rush through
the workout
good
so the focus here is on your front leg
job
[Music]
are you still breathing
the only competition is yourself
so listen to your body
flow with your body good job okay drop
it back down and we are changing to the
other side okay
now left leg forward right leg back are
we ready let's breathe in
and let's go up
release
lunge all the way back take a wide step
and push through your front heels
[Music]
there you go
up
[Music]
looking good
a few more
Stay With Me
solid reverse lunges
up
pull yourself back oops last one more
don't lose your balance there
uh just shake it out okay we're getting
back down on to the mat
three-legged dog with a crunch so let's
start in a high plank position okay
remember push into the floor
reach your leg up Point your knee
towards your elbow and push it up
do not rotate your hips too much okay
keep your hips squared drive it in
feel the work
on your abs good
push it up
stretch your back
drive it in
and good
remember breathe in as you drive your
leg up and breathe out as you crunch
two more up
feel the stretch
that's one more
up
and in okay
if you're with me stay in this plank
position if you need to get into a
child's pose all right let's work on the
opposite leg right leg up
drive it in good job
push it all the way back
look at your toes
and
elbow towards knee towards your elbow
good
nice
so remember to really push into the
floor
in
good job
and in
a few more
give it one more
three-legged dog
and just drop your knees oh if you need
to get into a child's purse all right
all right next let's focus on our core
and our obliques as well alternate side
plank so start in a high plank position
release one arm reach it all the way up
twist and release the other arm
up
good
good job
again remember to find your balance if
this is too much
you can always start on your knees
all that work we've put in it is going
to be a little bit more challenging
towards the end of this workout but stay
with me
I know you're strong you're looking
really strong
all right
let's push through
two more up
one more
up and drop it back down okay good news
let's lie down on the mat
but we're not done yet
so remember
keep your heels close to your butt get
into a good Bridge position
release drive your knee in straight leg
and back down okay so gaze straight
towards the ceiling squeeze your glutes
throughout
up
and down so do not drop your hips
squeeze
the butt
straight leg and back down as straight
as you can okay
really push your heel
into the ground
good
straight
looking really good
and down
and just drop it down okay now push
yourself back up let's get into a table
top position
you know this okay this is called crap
toe touch all we're going to do is
release one leg and try to tap your toes
all right good so looking like a crab
tapping your toes
good job
so really brace your core
suck your belly and reach for your toes
feel the stretch
along
your arms and your back as well try to
kick higher if you can kick it straight
up
if you're flexible you should be able to
straighten your legs
I'm a little bit tight on my hamstrings
up
last few more
one more
and just drop it down okay final
exercise all right final exercise and
you are done I promise you this now
let's get into a reverse position let's
get on to all fours and just hover your
knees off the mat and remember kick
through release your arm so opposite leg
with opposite arm kick through and just
release
the whole point here is to
be in a nice controlled movement do not
rush through the workout
getting back onto all fours and kick
good job
you're halfway there
release back
and release
nice
can we keep going this is your final
exercise
all right
that's two more one more
and just drop it back down okay
let's just get into a child's pose
and just
bring our heart rate back down okay
just breathe in and breathe out
you have worked hard for the past 25
minutes so let's just take this moment
to drive your heart rate back down
job and now slowly push yourself back up
okay guys really really well done I
don't know about you but I'm feeling
really really energized right now so I'm
ready to kick start my day or if you
want to you can end your day feeling
really amazing so be sure to check out a
lot more workout videos on my YouTube
channel if you haven't yet subscribed
then what are you doing go ahead and hit
the Subscribe button for new videos
every week and I will see you in my next
workout all the best let me know how
this workout felt in the comments below